can you explain about how the lineage
from
kim il-sung sort of through to now has
worked
because it's quite an interesting story
yeah so this is another irony right like
in communism you don't
have a king but north korea became a
kingdom
right the king's kings became not just a
king they became a god
for north koreans they so interesting
about kim your son
is that the first game his parents were
devout christians
so kim jong though okay if i copy bible
and tell him so when you become god you
don't have to be logical
you don't have to explain why things
work the way right like
it's a higher power like you know you
don't try to understand god's logic
so it becomes much easier to brainwash
in population
so he literally copied the bible saying
i'm a god
i love you guys so much so i'm giving
you my son
kim jong-il who's gonna work for the you
know the revolution of the country
but his body dies but don't believe that
he
spirits with us forever therefore he
came with your thoughts and minds and
how
many hair in your head exactly what the
bible says right the jesus came he died
and he spirits with us all the time
and that's how i even believe that kim's
were like reading my thoughts
i was even afraid to think people in
north korea
the thought crime i think him is not
like free
so that's how kimberson came as a
communist
and then he making this country
confiscate all the land
nationalize everything and he was i
think more dreamer he really
want to thought i think communism would
work
i don't know what he thought but however
when it came to his son they knew that
this thing is for themselves obviously
and
brutally purged every time the new king
comes
and now kim jong-un time the top of
fisher's
lifespan is only three years too so kim
jong-un
is killing everybody every three years
so
they don't get corrupt and then
consolidate power
so it cannot start to cool so when you
become a type elite
if you stand a long time you are going
to consolidate power
and get the build allies by kim jong
execute them and punishing them
every three years by doing that he get
eliminate any competition
where do you think the paranoia comes
from is this something that
they've been taught by their parents
have they got a
very strong genetic trait for just being
unbelievably anxious what's going on
i think they they even know what they're
doing is not acceptable
right like i mean he was killing uh this
type of vision in a meeting because he
was falling asleep
in a minute and then that guy right next
hour get executed in the fire squad
right so she knows that people are being
loyal to him and people are living in
that country not just because they want
to live there it's just out of fear
they're doing it
so i'm sure everybody he knows that so
clearly that
she's controlling the people through
fear only
nobody loves him nobody actually cares
take care of him and
nobody wants to be royalty on their own
so i think
in a way that paranoia is a legitimate
but she doesn't have to be that way
right if he tries to make things really
better
and why would anybody not want to be
there
it's interesting it's like a vicious
cycle when you mistreat people
because as you mistreat them they have
less faith in you which means that you
need to use more force in order to get
them to comply
which means that they believe in you
less which means you need to mistreat
them more which means you believe in you
less
and you can see how this happens i am
it's crazy thinking about this slow
descent as well as you say
it looks like 50 years ago like there
might have been a genuine dream that
this could have worked with some sort of
a balance
what do you think what do you think was
the worst
period for to be alive in north korea
over the last whatever sort of 60 years
or so 70 years
worst period i think is definitely the
90s after soviet union collapsed right
so
in the north korea began in the 50s
after the world war ii
the japan left and the korea became
independent
and korean war begins and then of course
america come defend south korea so
everything departed in 1953
from there on north korean economy was
heavily subsidized by soviet union and
china because that was a cold war they
wanted
the communism to win so they were like
why even the soviet union going bankrupt
themselves
they're heavily subsidized north korean
economy
but when they collapsed in 89 uh north
korea
that's when they really knew that coming
doesn't work
and you just spend everybody's money and
that's it everybody become dirty poor
right
so in the 90s that's when the regime
decided that okay the only success
measure that we are going to have is
keeping the 10 percent of the population
alive
that's for them is a success so as long
as they maintain
10 percent of life they think they do
not have to do a
thing about it so until the 90 percent
all die
they're gonna do a thing about it so
this is why
also they want the population to be weak
why do they starve us even though the
international community
begging north korea to feed its own
people
they want to give you money the u.n
wants begging to give food right
but north korea museum says no to all
the aids and all the medical aids
and the reason why they do that is that
because it so is to control people
when they're hungry like in north
koreans what we do is that when we get
up we eat the breakfast right
and what we are thinking is how are we
gonna find lunch
once you lunch like oh how am i gonna
make like fine dinner
if you make the one day you think okay i
made one day on earth
how am i gonna make tomorrow you
tomorrow is never guaranteed for you
you don't know like how you're gonna be
tomorrow so
in that mind people are very occupied as
a survivor
and then then they are not going to even
think about what is dictatorship what is
freedom
what is the outside world look like they
don't care about that
and kim jong-un have every every reason
to stop the population
and he is using the most inhumane
culture
to be of god right now it's very
difficult to think about putting a
revolution together
when all that you need to worry about is
your next meal for you and your family
yeah it's such a
it's such a effective control mechanism
obviously it's
awfully brutal but it works it gets the
job done
of not permitting any mental freedom
for people to think of those higher
abstractions i mean you know for you to
think
to be surprised by a day planner
yeah what's a day planner why would i
need to plan my day that's planned by
the state
yeah why didn't kim jong-il's
eldest son become leader
so kim jong-un didn't the kim jong-nam
who got assassinated right
so yeah that's an interesting story uh
kim jong-un had
four wives official wives and then like
how many ministries we don't even know
there's gonna be armies of them
so among those four kim jong-nam is
coming from the first
wife that which is alleged to my wife
and he was really loved by kim jong-il
however around like early 2000
kim jong-nam was visiting japan to go to
disneyland
with a fake passport on the way back he
got called and jones took
photos of him and then it became an
international
like embarrassment because north korea
is all about hating the west
by hating america hating japan hearing
the western civilization
and here is the heir to north korean
throne going to disneyland
so it was such an embarrassment and
that's when kim jong
kim jong-il were like almost banished to
him
and that's how he but the thing is kim
jong-nam was a
way more free spirit he wasn't
interested in like power he was
interested in control
he was more interested in like opening
up the economy let's
learn from the rest let's learn like
what we can do better
and he was more like flavor of a
chinese direction that chinese communist
party to which is the opening of the
economy
we don't have to change the party
communist party
but can we at least open the economy so
people get fit
fed but of course nursing regime like
then no we don't want that
so his ideology did not mean that what
his father
dreamed of and then his third wife
which was also plagiar squad that she
was i think a dancer
and she had a son kim jong-un which was
a second son
not even the first one he was very
ambitious
she was very brutal and cruel like his
own father
so kim jong-il saw kim jong-un and then
like oh my god i see myself in you
so you are gonna be the next deal leader
and he became one
so the kim jong-nam i'm trying to keep
up with all the names here
he um he was misaligned to be the sort
of leader that everybody needed in any
case
do you think he was killed only a couple
of years ago he was assassinated
um but it seems like the trip to japan
was a convenient excuse
for somebody that probably didn't meet
the criteria to be a leader in any case
yeah no he wasn't gonna be that ruto
and kill the uncle like literally kim
jong-un is way more brutal any previous
schemes
he used this like aircraft that shoots
down the airplane
he used that to execute people so it
makes the people become a dust literally
like
you become into pieces of this blood and
it's like that's a thing
that's how it executes people and to
show the actual terror
and but as you said right you gotta use
more fear as the time goes by
and more fear and fear fear and there's
no ever ending to it
and kim jong-un like literally when he
executing his own uncle
said she has no place to be buried in
this land
so make him into dust that's why he they
use the aircraft that's
gone almost to shoot him down so he
became into pieces and nobody could
collect his bodies
what was the what was the outcome
because he got was it a nerve agent
in singapore or japan
no malaysia that was a brother but the
uncle when kim jong-un was killing
his uncle by the kim jong-nam's case
like the nerve agent
that they wrapped in his nose and face
and then he just died within a few
minutes
and his body was sent to pyongyang
afterwards and we don't know what they
did with his body but
he was scared and uh and it was so sad
because
he was providing information to the u.s
intelligence
for the last 10 years and then u.s
didn't do a
thing about protecting him like he was
on that tree meeting a cia agent in the
northern island of malaysia for two days
after he was giving all the information
and when he was about to go home back to
his family
they killed him and this is so sad like
nobody protects anybody at this point
did you hear the story of why the two
women that rubbed the rag in his face
did it or why they said so they claimed
that they were that they'd been told
that they were doing a prank on a tv
show
is that right yeah they they thought oh
this is gonna be some prank tv show
this makes no sense i mean these girls
were like
not touching themselves the thing they
were going washing their hands like
very carefully that i mean if that was a
prank why would they do that
so but the thing is point is that i
think even those girls were victims
they were i don't i don't really don't
think that's
important they knew or not the most
important thing is
how there is no revenge or no
accountability
you know even jamal khashoggi the saudi
journalist
we all know that when he got chopped off
into pieces in the saudi council in
turkey
there's no consequences for killing a
distance
that is the word that we are living in
like of course people talk about
injustice or any other time but
this is a clear injustice these are
clear murderers
it's a good control it's a great control
mechanism right if
as a dissident you know that not only
are you probably going to be killed
but the people that are going to kill
you aren't going to be brought to
account
and the more that this happens the more
that dissidents killers
aren't put on trial or aren't called to
account for the things that they've done
the more fear it instills in people that
want to speak out against regimes that
need it
and the more it empowers the regimes
that want to control the population
absolutely i mean when the man putin
like poisons his distance
i mean mbs saudis do that north koreans
does that like even
there's really no accountability at this
point and this is
i think one of the justice area that we
are struggling
and i think that's this is i don't know
how to even solve this but the thing is
what a joke the i mean saudis in chinese
and russians deciding who are the human
rights violators
at the u.n so this is a almost a joke to
me that
michael is a job michael malus will have
a solution for this he's always got a
solution for
for mad anarchy lordship different
countries
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace
you